he's got what in the backyard at krog a
hedgehog yeah and it said no it's not
dead people oh well that's where the
head jobs live in gardens police
emergency reckon up a police I have
sports I read did you stole my mana
who's stalling your money did the mall
give me money but for the same as well
but that's not something that you should
ring 999 was this is this I want me
money but what is very important what
has happened I've been ripped off you've
been ripped off in what way I ordered a
pizza 45 minutes right starting
delivered by my face nice not an
emergency and only nice not a police
matter sleet emergency yeah I wonder
please please what's the problem well I
mean I put a portion one in this vending
machine and refusing money back and I
need that money from making an angel you
called the police emergency line because
you put some money in a vending machine
and it's not giving it your back we are
not in the bucket hospital electric
shock though you need to contact the
hospital this is in absolutely not a
police emergency line you put some money
in a vending machine at hospital you
need so we're not given in the work
we're not even a new Brian need to
contact the vending machine company I'm
going to clear the line now because
you're holding it all for people who
have genuine emotion